ja mehr als fünf monate krieg in der
ukraine und auch heute wollen wir uns
militärische lage am an land ansehen und
wir wollen uns ansehen mit welche
taktiken mit welchen waffen denn beide
seiten versuchen diesen krieg für sich
zu entscheiden und wir haben eine
ziemlich schlechte nachricht für die
ukraine nämlich seit einigen wochen
haben wir einen relativen stillstand
hier an der front vor allem im osten
nach der eroberung von lohans großen
provinz hier ist es relativ still
geworden aber wir wissen das seit heute
morgen hier ein neuer russischer vorstoß
stattfindet ich zeige es mal ungefähr
mit einem pfeil rein hier geht es raus
aus diesem gebiet aus den eroberten
gebiet und richtung bach mut eine
weitere stadtbach mit kurz vor kramer
toski hier angegriffen wird wo wir von
der ukrainischen armee auch erfahren
haben dass dort seit heute morgen
gekämpft wird das also schlechte
nachricht für die ukraine und
nachrichten die noch mal zeigen die
russen sind eben noch nicht am ende die
russen dringend weiter vor und wie sie
das machen das sehen wir hier mit
brutalster feuerkraft das hier zu sehen
ein bm 21 rakete mehrfach raketenwerfern
vom typ grad der hier 41 raketen
abschießt und wir müssen uns das einfach
mal vorstellen das ist diese diese pure
masse an feuerkraft diese pure masse an
zerstörung die russin hat hier immer
wieder obwohl schon soviel ja selbst
zerstört wurde obwohl sie so viel
verloren haben immer wieder rein feiert
das ist tatsächlich etwas was ihnen
bisher doch noch hier auch im osten
zumindest ein gleichgewicht wenn ich
sogar die oberhand vergibt aber wir
müssen uns auch mal angucken wo denn
diese einschläge sind denn russlands
russland strategie ist tatsächlich
quantität statt qualität also wir sehen
hier über einschläge wahrscheinlich hier
das ziel gewesen was wir da gesehen
haben wir sind übel eine übereinstimmung
und erstmal könnte man sagen ja das ist
ja völlig ungenau und wie kann man sowas
über funktionieren ja das funktioniert
eben wenn ich 41 raketen aus einem
einzigen werfer abschießen und ich habe
davon hunderte werfer die immer wieder
jeden tag aufs neue eben diese
ukrainische anlage hier beschießen und
irgendwann hat man sie eben völlig klein
geschossen die ukraine machen das ganz
anders sie setzen auf westlichen
hightech sie setzen auf präzision also
qualität statt quantität und wir sehen
jetzt hier ein eingegraben dass
russisches geschützt das ist eine
selbstfahrer fette vom typ 2 1 acacia
die ist ja eingebildet und diese
einbuddeln half ihm viele jahre lang
weil man gesagt hat
butt ist dann kann man schlecht
getroffen werden das ist aber eben nicht
so gegen high tech artillerie aus dem
westen hier setzt die ukraine als die
sogenannte m 777 ein ein britisches
geschützt was die usa in gespendet haben
und wir sehen wie danach diese die wir
eben gesehen haben diese diese
art ranches diese gräben die dort
ausgehoben wurden wie die eben anfangen
zu brennen und wieder drin wir sehen uns
jetzt uns doch einmal kurz an eben haben
wir noch gesehen dass geschützte drinnen
jetzt ist es vollkommen verschwunden man
sieht also fast gar nichts mehr davon
und das passiert nicht nur einmal
sondern das passiert mehr macht das
heißt sobald die ukrainischen drohen die
geschützte hier sehen und feststellen wo
sie sind jetzt haben wir zwei weitere
ist es ihnen eben auch möglich mit
diesen tricks schützen aus dem westen
hier anzugreifen und wir sehen jetzt
hier ein weiteres geschützt was brennt
und hier ein munitions lkw auch noch der
brennt das heißt die ukrainer setzten
weiterhin auf präzision auf hightech und
sie sagen wenn wir euch sehen und dann
können wir auch beschießen und dann
haben wir eine chance gegen euch es ist
einfach die pure masse gegen die sie
hier vorgehen als letztes wollen wir uns
einen video angucken ja was erstmal ganz
hübsch aussieht wir sehen hier einen
sonnenblumenfeld und in diesem
sonnenblumenfeld drin versteckt sich
hier allerdings ein ukrainisches
flugabwehrgeschütz vom typ book m1 und
das schießt jetzt gleich eine rakete ab
da sehen wir es die raketen abgeschossen
hat etwa eine reichweite von 20
kilometer in der länge und zwölf
kilometer in der höhe und wir sehen dann
auch gleich dass die rakete ein ziel
trifft und sie schießt ihn nicht etwa
auf ein flugzeug die russen traut sich
nicht mehr mit ihren flugzeugen über die
ukraine seit mehreren monaten sondern
auf eine drohne auf eine online 10
drohne die ebenhoch geschickt wurde von
den russen um zu gucken wo sind die
ukraine jetzt haben wir da hinten sehen
jetzt die kleine explosion lasst es der
explosion gekommen und wir sehen gleich
nochmal die abgeschossene drohne also
eine drohne die auf die geschickt wurde
um zu sehen wo sind die ukraine wo kämen
wir sie beschießen und hier haben wir
einige fotos bist du also ein foto von
dieser online 10 drohne wir sehen das
ist die gesamte länge hier vorne der
antrieb mit dem propeller die ihn
abgeschossen wurde von diesem buch
system und einige fragen sich ja wie
kann man denn mit so einem high tex oder
mit einem großen system auf so eine
kleine drohne vorher lohnt sich das denn
überhaupt und ja es droht sich denn
diese drohnen spielen wie gesagt aus wo
sind die einheiten und die artillerie
und die raketen schießen dann genau
dahin das heißt ukrainische leben zu
retten müssen die ukraine mit solchen
riesigen raketen auf solche kleine
drohnen schießen
[Musik]